Aretha Franklin the Queen of Soul has
died
[Music]
the legendary entertainer is one of the
best-selling artists of all time and one
more than a dozen Grammy Awards over the
course of her career becoming an
inspiration to artists across
generations we think of when they show
all these new performers coming out
seeing your material that have been
influenced by you but you're proud of
that and I think it's wonderful it's
wonderful yes in 1987
Aretha became the first female performer
ever to be inducted into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame and in 1994 she was
the Kennedy Center Honors youngest
recipient ever it's like a fairy tale
almost it's um it's been exquisite
absolutely exquisite she received the
nation's highest civilian award in 2005
a Presidential Medal of Freedom
get out
but the star stepped away from the
spotlight in 2017 citing a failing
health this is a difficult question to
ask before her ask anybody how are you
well don't ask me difficult questions
darling I'm the lady next door when I
come offstage I'm just the lady next
door I'm everyday people
[Music]
you